ich kann viel lauter punkten als du ich
stelle mainz nachträglich lauter ich
mach mainz auch leute
und wie 30 oder so also mein haus was
mittlerweile eigentlich keines mehr ist
wir haben unser ursprünglicher spot
media house ungefähr der originale älter
hier liegen auch noch sachen von mir
wtf in der crew haben wie kommen die
daten hin
vielleicht sind die rübergeflogen als
ich dich da gekelterte kann sein alter
da sage ich jetzt als lager ich jetzt
erstmal in sachen man sammle ich das auf
dass die noch nicht die sports sind wir
sind so weit weg dass der tank inaktiver
alter wenn du jetzt genau in dem moment
die spawn wo ich davor stehende häuser
rum
das ist mir schon passiert mit kev
zusammen und es waren sogar diamanten
glaub ich lauf hier brennt ja auch noch
obwohl er kommt mein freund das war
knapp
vorher geht schon wieder so tief runter
jetzt komm endlich wieder wir müssen
jetzt die kaffeebauern aber das geht
runter könnte also schon mal die
grundmauern bauen weil ich habe hier so
viel eisen dass ich alles für die dings
verwenden dass wir alles verwenden
können für die werkzeuge ja dann fragst
du dann nachher werkzeuge rein und ich
baue das teil ja können wir machen ich
bin jetzt auch auf dem rückweg bloß
immer wenn ich eisen c muss nummer
anhaltung mitnehmen ich habe insgesamt
46 alten tageslicht jetzt bin ich oben
gut dann nehme ich schon mal da war aber
nur drei rennhelm egal
das letzte eisen hiermit auch hier geht
es noch mal rein
denn hier ist nochmal eisenach wie lange
du nachher die sache rein passt schon so
viel einst so schön
nein meine krims krams kiste ist fast
voll kitas hierhin was hört nicht auf
fledermaus das holz das keine ahnung
essen glaub ich jetzt auch noch mal so
schön so viel eisen wie viel habe ich
hoffe ich hab das ganze nicht die ganze
zeit liegen lassen ich hab ich nicht was
ich habe ein steak
ich habe anderthalb 6 grad mal das
obwohl ich eigentlich nur einsammeln war
die ganze zeit wie sagst du den 36 ja
noch von damals so ich dachte nur jetzt
von der reichen von da nein nein quatsch
da solltest du nicht so viel denken den
da kommt nichts bei rum mir leid
mybet mein vorurteil kennen
ich glaube man kann auch sagen ich hab
das ist noch wichtiger richtige herrn
sowie paypal sicher report fest
paypal slogan ist sicher hier und du
hast gerade falsch falsch aber nicht
steigerbar genauso wie sicher nicht
steigerbar ist also nicht zumindest
nicht so extrem gut dann passt auch
wieder nicht herzlicher als doch richtig
ja aber es heißt ich sicherer sondern
sich her er auf paypal punkt com
oder paypal punkt.de zumindest das
sichere er aber auf jeden fall zwei ich
glaube zwei mal mehr als sichere ich bin
auf jeden fall im dschungel rausgekommen
und ich fange jetzt glaube ich mal
anders links zu bauen alter der weiß die
zuschauer aus du glaubst es nicht ich
glaube ich brauche mein haus von oben
enormer neue von daher danke bitte werde
ich gerne die sachen da gehabt
er ist bisschen holz gegeben müssen gibt
hause finden so sagt es in welche
richtung was nach f3 okay weil da wo ich
denke dass es sein müsste ist nur wasser
so ein riesen und her das dachte ich mir
auch wie kaputt so läuft auch rentiert
wenn du wenn du daher läuft glaube ich
selbst auch noch an zwei riesigen
schluchten vorbei miteinander gehen als
christa vorbei an der kiste einfach
großer dank genug essen das heißt ich
keine springen sprinten
solange das herz begehrt so lag es
begehrt solange es begehrten karten aber
ich weiß nicht aber ich glaube ich bin
im richtigen weg obwohl wir zu hause ein
streit weg und hohen lps neben mir grad
gewesen
ich hab ihn eiskalt ignoriert habe so
getan als kenne ich nicht portugal
vielleicht hat ja ich bin hand naja ich
bin hart
zb hier in holmes - keine ahnung wie das
kind von speed4 zb habe ich bloß so
winter filme bild sein haus trotzdem
komplett unterirdisch haben oder willst
das ist auch am ende dass es nicht nur
unterdigisheim könnte man hier so
genialen zum glas enkel machen so
richtig fett so nee ich mache das schon
noch unterirdisch aber ich glaub ich
mach die treppe mal komplett weg und
macht dann hier einfach irgendwas hin
ich hab jetzt erstmal eine freifläche
apple store in new york dann ist so eine
heim nicht komplett lazo fehler so war
sowie in der luft wichtig für amiga
minecraft klappt nicht so super jetzt
hier das aber ein schönes haus gefunden
ständig zu 800 witz das ist ja echt so
machen
ja aber das problem ist nur mit krippen
und so das alles ja was
ja wenn die dann ja ich meine dass wenn
ich da rein laufen oder willst du jetzt
türen reinmachen cluster noch recht wenn
diese
ja schon ich meine wir müssen eigentlich
noch zwei kisten ingenieuren und eine
soll auf jeden fall in die natur
eingebunden seien zeige ja eben aber das
ding ist ja dass wir hier so leicht
creeper einlaufen
nein nein da kommen schon noch was drauf
deswegen will ich da noch was willst du
als tür machen ja und als tür als tür
überlegen wie viele minuten haben jetzt
will für neuen folge sind für kommentar
frage ja wir sind gerade direkt
miteinander folgen
jetzt ist gerade die der der die fünfte
folge an
die sechste bei mir eine stunde nacht
nämlich gerade auf die 5 wir sind gerade
mitten in der fünften erst so auch so
ich dachte wir fangen gerade direkt eine
neue an
er soll die frage jetzt stellen oder
sich warten ist es 115 ist weil dann ist
es direkt an ein beginn der neuen folge
war jetzt okay frage von szombathely
kalt ihr mal darüber reden als was ihr
später arbeiten wollt beziehungsweise ob
ihr studieren oder eine ausbildung
warum bin ich war völlig natürlich da
gehört 1200 hier wieder eine verkleidung
oder einfach nur deine kitzelte komplett
leer ja sicherheitsvorkehrungen vor
verrückten kontrakte
alle sachen oben rein gelegt dass immer
noch geheimnisse
ja und es sagt ja auch nie bestimmt
nicht wo jungen jetzt gehe raus wo angst
vor dir
ich mach das nächste ich guck doch nur
der lose herum und marc ist ein
laufender fackeln rom ist keine ware
sofort mitbekommen
könnt ihr mal darüber reden als was ihr
später arbeiten wolf und bzw
wir studieren wollt oder ausbildung ich
kann mir schon vorstellen was hier
hinter ist da willst du die frage nach
erstmal nach könnt ihr mal in folge
noch fünf minuten medienpädagoge finde
ich ganz witzig aber so ganz genau weiß
nicht ob ich glaube wir den atv steht
was man später machen möchte hat auch
jemand medienpädagogik solchen seiten
halbjahr das hat er voll von mir geklaut
das sei ja schon voll auf den videos
gesagt ja aber was eben madame ich
wunder mich was an medienpädagogin weil
pädagoge ist doch etwas unterrichtenden
pädagogen also mit bildung eigentlich
verbunden pädagoge und als du mir das
erklärt hat ist meinte das irgendwie
nicht so viel mit für bildungsferne aber
dann kannst du es gerne noch mal
erklären weil ich glaube ich den
allermeisten nichts darunter vorstellen
können
das ist einfach das so zum beispiel
guckst wie werbung sage ich mal die im
fernsehen läuft die auf plakaten ist
oder wie ganz einfache wahlplakate sage
ich mal einfluss auf spezielle
altersgruppen sage ich mal haben das
wertet man dann aus und so weiter und
warum bin ich eigentlich an deinem haus
gefoltert das ding ins haus bauen dann
zum beispiel was gibt's jetzt was gab's
nur zum beispiel
es gab vor einem jahr oder so einen
relativ jungen wahlkandidaten hier in
nordrhein westfalen bei in seiner partei
keine ahnung blabla jedenfalls war der
noch relativ junge alle hatten gedacht
das ist ein milchbubi hier den winter
nie gewählt und dann hat er extra
für dieses wahlplakat sich einen ehering
weil er halt eine frau hat hatte sich
extra ganz fett mit photoshop oder mit
irgendwas zu hervorheben lassen dass man
oder halt einfach den so eine kamera
gezeigt dass die leute sehen okay er ist
verheiratet das heißt er ist vielleicht
auch nicht so ein wilder bursche und
dann wählen doch mehr leute ihn dass man
sowas analysiert das stellt sich vor das
hätte ich immer als medienwissenschaft
bzw kommunikationsmanager schafft das
hat er alles deshalb wie vor gilt
kommunikations und medienwissenschaft
das ist eigentlich so was hätte ich
immer gedacht und dann gibt es noch
mediengestaltung das passt sehr alles
darunter ein in dem sack ich mehr
gestaltung ist gestaltet und das ist
halt dass er jeden fall gehört alles zu
medien oder muss darauf achten was ich
mache geschieht ja sagt es für
medienpädagogik geschäftet sich als
wissenschaftliche disziplin mit allen
erzieherischen frage probleme und themen
die mit medien zusammenhängen unter
media erzieherischen fragen probleme und
themen wasser ganz kurze zwischenwasser
daran interessiert im moment hast du
hast du denn jetzt hast du hälst helles
holz für mich nein aber wer mir jede
menge bäume von dem ein helles holz
bekommt dann fällst du das euro dann
fällst du hast doch selbst sein
abrasiert wie du kannst du doch die
partei wie meinst du das was habe ich da
passiert den den einbaum dass das laub
davon abrasiert das ist aber das ist
nicht alles als dunkles holz
was ja dann birkenholz daher ich weiß
und das holst du mir weil ich mache das
schon alles selber machen was brauche
ich ahne ich habe dinge da mache ich so
ein komisches ding erst wenn ich etwas
gut aussieht so eine komische spitze ok
du spontan aber auch die kisten kann ich
auch machen
kisten plus inhalt dann mache ich ja
noch beleuchtung kostet schals aus all
das kommt fast an minecraft markets ran
ich schau mal das war doch so schön am
anfang wie sie sind jetzt so schlecht
verstehe ich nicht brauche noch glas
mache ich was ich bin dafür dass wir uns
schleunigst diamanten besorgen und dann
obsidian zu haben uns um sie ob sie den
kisten zu machen also ändert es weil da
kann der andere nicht reingucken haben
wir endlich einen sicheren jazz welcher
stark der vwd zerstörst kannte da nicht
ein inhalt kommen
wir brauchen für evtl da wollte ich erst
mal glasscheiben haben heute dachte ich
ich hatte eigentlich klar scheint aber
jetzt habe ich sogar selber noch
interessieren
so jetzt mit aber ein bisschen beeilen
denn jetzt ist die letzte folge die
sechste folge die wir alleine sind
die beginnt jetzt schon die beginnt
jetzt ein paar sekunden 30 ungefähr
vermisst thema gar nicht ehrlich
behandelt
ja du musst noch ganz schnell sagen und
trägern schnell die frage was wir ja was
später man wollte es aber auch schwer
also auf jeden fall studieren richtung
steht aber noch nicht fest aber auf
jeden fall was studieren
es sind verschiedene richtungen weil
mich alles möglich interessiert aber es
dann auch um abhängt was man im später
im endeffekt wirklich damit machen kann
ein paar beispiele sonst haben die leute
gar nichts davon
kommunikationswissenschaften aber mich
hat auch mal vwl interessiert mich doch
mal vbl vwl
vw das ist volkswirtschaftslehre oder
politikwissenschaftler mich interessiert
aber so frage ich da was man im
endeffekt machen kann und ob es wirklich
den später so interessant ist wie man
sich das mal vorgestellt habe heutzutage
muss man auch nicht mehr sein leben lang
das gleiche machen
darum kann ich mir gut vorstellen
irgendwas hin zu studieren was ihn
interessiert was vielleicht später jetzt
nicht irgendwie genau man lernt da jedes
da die handgriffe die man später im job
braucht sondern ein allgemeines wissen
im endeffekt auch allgemeine bildung
nächste folge so ich muss hier geht noch
ein bisschen weh aber ich hab selber
oder ich hab so glaube ich das holz auch
ja ich muss jetzt zerstören er ich muss
wieder errichten was du hier mutwillig
zerstört hast meine playstation sich
daran gemacht ich hab gleich gemacht
ja ja ja ja ja ich mache während der
aufnahmen playstation an während die
ganze der probelauf wird
ich denke er hat frei jetzt halt die
klappe oder töte dich
man sei sich aber nun helm wichtig was
ausgerüstet hab ich ja besser und ich
hab noch eine a ha 666 aber besser aber
ich bin effektiver damit ich kann viel
lauter als du ich stelle mainz
nachträglich lauter ich mach mainz auch
leute immer zwei mal mehr als zwei
wirklich richtig laut glaube ich daher
in den total vermietet so ich mich
morgens wenn man ihn fliegen vom stuhl
das mache ich